Judge Richard a posner when did you
first think of yourself as a public
intellectual oh I when people started
calling me that a few years ago we're
hadn't even heard the term where's it
come from apparently it was invented by
a fella named Russell Jacob II about 15
years ago so it's quite recent how do
you define it a person who's using the
the ideas from the you know cultural
intellectual tradition could be
philosophical could be you know
political economic sociological literary
so on to communicate with the public
about things that that you know the
ordinary people are interested in it is
there a name that automatically comes to
mind when you think public intellectual
George Orwell would be the one of the
great 20th century public intellectuals
Rachel Carson Rachel Carson a scientist
but writing for the public about
environmental problems that public
became interested in as result of her
work
betty Friedan is another Edmund Wilson
great literary critic who you know wrote
about political matters as well again
trying to reach a general audience with
real ideas not not not pop culture ideas
in your own life when did you know that
you're going to be an intellectual oh no
bookworm as a child but I really think
of intellectual not not as a
professional person not as a lawyer or a
judge as such but someone who is you
know again trying to reach out to the
public about the ideas about the about
the concerns of the public as opposed to
strictly professional concerns how long
have you been a judge twenty years
what's the court the US Court of Appeals
for the Seventh Circuit in Chicago
covers three Midwestern states Illinois
Indiana and Wisconsin so
there are these regional courts of
appeals there between the federal
district courts the trial courts and the
US Supreme Court what were you doing
right before that I was a law professor
at University of Chicago how long did
you do that 12 years and before that I
had one teaching job before that at
Stanford for a year but before that I
was in Washington I had a series of
government jobs I was a law clerk the
Supreme Court and I worked for the
Justice Department Federal Trade
Commission
I had a stint on a one of President
Lyndon Johnson's Task Forces on
communications policy so I spent six
years in Washington before I went into
teaching you were a liberal Democrat for
a while and then changed oh well when I
was when I was young I would have
considered myself a liberal not
necessarily a Democrat but yeah I did I
did change over the years
what did liberal mean then Oh in the
early 60s I was very the first
presidential election I was eligible to
vote in 1960 I voted for Kennedy with
enthusiasm so was that kind of
liberalism why I decided was not a party
person but I did consider myself liberal
in the early when did you change shift
well I began shifting the late sixties I
was I was very disturbed by the outburst
a kind of student radicalism in the late
60s and a kind of general sense of
national disintegration I didn't like
the radicals the unpatriotic left that
became very conspicuous in the late 60s
early 70s and also when I started
teaching became interested in economics
I realized there was a lot more to
capitalism than I had thought
so so I moved gradually rightward not
all the way though by any means how did
you get appointed to the court well this
was the this was the this was 1981 this
was the outset of Reagan's first term
and the administration wanted to change
the kind of ideological cops
of the federal appellate courts and they
made a real effort to fly in
conservative law professors of whom
there weren't the great many and appoint
them so a Bork was one Nino Scalia was
another Ralph winter on the second
circuit and I was one of one of that
group undergraduate at Yale Harvard law
grad teacher from Stanford a teacher
from Chicago lawyer supreme
peels court judge do you live in another
world compared to the average person
when you're thinking through the the
world I suppose yeah I mean one of the
problems we had the very educated people
who are immersed in books and esoteric
intellectual issues yeah there's a
disconnect between people like that and
they you know ordinary people I think
it's dangerous for the you know
intellectuals to get too remote from
experiences ordinary life do you do
anything to try to stay in touch with
ordinary life I read the newspaper I'm
not completely detached from what's
going on where did you meet your wife in
Cambridge Massachusetts I was a law
student she had just graduated from
Radcliffe and had come back to Cambridge
was working we happen to have apartments
that were diagonally across from each
other in the same building that's how we
met do you have what do you have in
common
what are we have in common when it comes
to the intellectual world well she's a
very intelligent person and she she
reads she reads a lot and so we yeah we
share intellectual interests got a
couple kids where are they are not kids
anymore
no they're there
mid to late 30s one is a works for
Morgan Stanley in New York Securities
analyst and the other teaches law at the
University of Chicago however I do
understand from reading other articles
about you you do have a relationship
with a cat I do have a cat to whom I'm
devoted but I'm not sure that I'm not
sure that a cat is I don't I don't think
a cat is a proper surrogate for the
average American so I don't think I can
claim to be connected to my fellow
Americans by my cat but you did you did
say though that the cat would like your
wife better as you like the cat likes
you yes it's characteristic of cats to
pick one person to favor you know now is
it's unusual for you to be in a position
of answering questions in the last 20
years that's true as a judge yeah we are
you aware one times the the lawyers get
sometimes we upset the lawyers and they
start asking us questions that's just
somewhat impertinent but I'm happy to
answer them you know everybody always
wants to know about you how do you do it
how do you sit on that bench and then
write but you've written over 30 books
yes well I'm it's it's you could say
it's obsessive compulsive behavior I I
like to write read write that's what I
do and also the more you do that the
easier it becomes as true of everything
now in what time frame cuz I know that
you got a lot of publicity on this book
because of your chart your list yeah
public intellectuals what time frame did
you write this book I think basically a
year although I incorporated into it
some materials from earlier earlier
writings I think about about a year but
you seriously part time not thank you
what time of day do you can you spend
writing how do you break up your
schedule Oh
I work pretty much seven days and seven
nights a week I mean not all together
obviously there's some social
engagements or your travel or something
but there must the tide to try to I do
try to work actually try to work every
day of the year even if I can only do a
few hours work a day it's that you know
you can do a lot in a few hours so you
know if you're careful about budgeting
your time and you apply yourself you can
you can do a lot and I do have
assistants I have academic research
assistants University of Chicago I have
law clerks to help me with research
legal research on opinions so the
subtitle a study of decline the public
intellectual end to climb yeah give us
some a reason why or give us an example
well I think well there's always a great
the the pitfall in trying to try to try
and identify it sort of a quality trend
is that you tend to consider the the
best of the past with the average of the
present because you've forgotten the
worst of the past that's that's
disappeared so that's a danger but as
you look back at the really influential
public intellectuals of history you know
starting with Socrates and Seneca and
Cicero and Voltaire and John Stuart Mill
then coming into the coming into 20th
century with Orwell and Western or while
I mention Edmund Wilson John Maynard
Keynes and coming you know right into
the 50s and 60s with people like betty
Friedan and Rachel Carson but now as we
look around although there are a lot of
very intelligent people who are public
intellectuals you know writing for for
the public it's hard to see them as
people are going to have the kind of
influence now I think they're exceptions
henry kissinger an exception built the
freedoms exception but these are now
elderly people and and I think the
reason what what has happened is
as universities have grown and as the
discriminatory barriers to university
employment have fallen kind of more and
more brilliant intellectuals find
themselves sucked into the safe life of
a university professor with tenure and
good salaries and so on not this
hand-to-mouth existence that so many
public intellectuals had you know
writing for but actually trying to live
on pittance from you know for writing
magazine articles so so we're and and
but the people but the the kind of
Faustian pact contra professor is you
become a specialist you live in a kind
of cloistered world and your ability to
see the problems of ordinary people
discuss those problems have a generalist
bread you just kind of is is withered by
your by your career path what do you
think of tenure I think tenure is
probably unbalanced a bad idea
it's got a it has an unfortunate kind of
self selection means it selects for
people who really are not risk-takers
and and and and that imparts a kind of
atmosphere to university kind of
timidity and kind of intellectual
conservatism so I mean the traditional
argument for tenure was that it was
necessary to protect people who had
unpopular views but you know what's odd
about universities is very strong
atmosphere of conformity in universities
you know it goes under the name now of
political correctness but there's always
been tremendous self-censorship in the
university community and a lot of you
know imitative nurse and so I'm not sure
tenure to some extent protects unpopular
views but and also you know any kind of
tenure of judges
it's going to it's it's just gonna
manufacture a lot of Deadwood because
people can't be fired just don't I just
not going to be on their toes to the
same extent as people whose jobs are
insecure
how much do you teach these days I don't
eat very much I teach we have a quarter
system in Chicago I teach a course in
one quarter and a seminar in another
quarter so it's fair it's about a third
of us with 20 years on the bench and at
roughly 20 years in the classroom which
which one is the best where do you enjoy
it which one do you enjoy the most
oh if I had to choose well I think I
think of the I think the judge ship
certainly as my primary job and I enjoy
it very much and yeah I would prefer to
be a judge than a professor but that's
that's a personal choice not not
everybody's choice now you know most
judges don't write publicly well
especially the ones who were professors
before they became judges do you have
any restrictions on what you can write
yeah we're not allowed to make public
comments which would include in in
writing on pending lawsuits or impending
lawsuits no we're you know a lawsuit is
about to be filed in a matter so that's
an indication and what was your role in
the microsoft case I was asked by the
judge presiding over the case to mediate
that is to try to bring the two sides
together to settle the case how much of
your time did you have to spend on that
well the mediation lasted for three and
a half months and I I did spend a great
deal of time
so when you're doing that do you you
don't sit no seven sir no I was still
sitting III was sitting but we don't the
appellate judges federal appellate
judges don't actually sit actually hear
cases that many days of the year we hear
we hear six cases a day but we only sit
about thirty days a year and that's 180
cases and there are also cases that
aren't orally argued so it's not a
trivial workload but in terms of the
days you actually have to be present and
sitting there relatively fused so you
know I you know I can take a few months
and be concentrating heavily on other
quelana
microsoft mediation while still sitting
a few days during that period and the
Seventh Circuit based in Chicago has how
many judges on it eleven sort of judges
regular active service as it's called
and several others who are kind of
semi-retired but sit part are you say in
your book that John Stuart Mill was
probably what the most influential most
public intellectual in the last two
centuries certainly one of the most yes
Karl Marx probably more influential for
the bad but mill of the good guys yes
one of the most disciplined what was
good about it
bad mill well as a public intellectual
his his most important work is in a
short book on liberty in which he
advocates a form of liberalism which I
because they're very tried by modern
standards describe myself as a
conservative but what mill said
basically was that the only business of
government is to protect people in the
you know kind of peaceful enjoyment of
their you know whatever they want to do
so you know his so he thought people
should be allowed to do whatever they
wanted to do as long as they weren't
hurting other people so that's
liberalism in both the economic and a
personal area I guess now we think of
that as of this is libertarianism
includes free speech but also you know
freedom to engage in business activities
without the heavy hand of government so
I think that's a great program for for
our society for any society but and it
has been very influential how did you
reach the conclusion that he was that
important oh that's just a that's just a
guess
there's no way of measuring historical
influence really I don't think you write
a lot about a lot of people you write a
lot about Robert Putnam in Bowling Alone
and page 319 you say the virtues that
Putnam stresses are real what's he
talking about
what virtues oh he he's talking about
the need to have some sense of
communities the ability to engage in
some national projects you can't have
everybody's so individualistic that
there's no cooperative activity with
with other people I think that's this
sound point you say about a number of us
who grew up in the 50s do not regret the
displacement of many of those virtues
and of the culture they formed by the
freer more individualistic faster pace
richer more varied and more exciting and
if also more vertiginous vertiginous
society of the present right yeah well I
talked about Putnam in a chapter which
is basically about nostalgia and its
people in middle age and elderly people
tend to look back and they're very
conscious of anything that's been lost
since they were young they're less
conscious of the gains often because
it's difficult for older people to
adapt to new new things so he looks back
to the 40s and 50s as nowhere where
there was more there was more conformity
was more homogeneity in the society and
so they they were good I remember from I
grew up in the 50s and you didn't have
to lock your car ever people never
bother to lock their cars they didn't
often didn't father lock their houses so
yeah there were nice things about the
50s country was less congested so on but
there have been enormous gains since
which the nostalgia tend to over look
and I prefer our modern you know more
heterogeneous more individualistic
society although I recognize some loss
take the book Bowling Alone what impact
if in your opinion did that have on any
part of our society and is it good or
bad that looks like that or written
books like yours your written who's
listening I don't think the social the
impact on society as a whole of these
books is it's substantial Bowling Alone
certainly we received a lot of attention
is a well written well received by
academics by sociological sociologists
and political scientists it sounds a
chord you know there's of nostalgia
concern about the country where it's
going song but as far as actual impact I
I don't I I doubt that it's significant
so why did public intellectuals do what
they do what's what do you think their
goal is oh I think well I think I think
the main thing probably is that people
very much like to have like to be famous
like to have their name in print like to
be on television like to be celebrities
like people to say oh I saw you on
television I read your op-ed piece I
think also there's a sense of of power
you know telling the country what to do
is to knowing maybe listening but still
you have the sense you don't it's hard
to realize the one that's often speaking
into the into the void now for some of
these people there's there's a
significant financial payoff you know
it's like a tournament there are very
few winners but there's a few public
intellectuals who have made very
lucrative speaking or book or or
bestseller book careers out of public
intellectuals why do people go and
listen why they listen I think one of
the reasons they listen is that these
people or some of them are genuine
celebrities you recognize them you know
people like Henry Kissinger some of them
I mentioned Kissinger Ken are actually
extremely intelligent people and they're
worth listening to and others are glib
and and funny and shocking and so
there's an entertainment value even if
you don't take seriously what what
you're watching or hearing but in
addition to that and I think I think a
bad quality of public intellectual
activity is that a lot of is sort of
building solidarity with a with a
political position that is most people
are reading or watching or hearing the
public intellectuals who are
articulating their views so if you see
that some you know celebrated and
credentialed and highly articulate
person is stating your views your
reinforced in those views and so I think
there's some tendency of polarization
the left the lefties listened to the
left-wing intellectuals enter and you
know full of indignation so on and the
right-wing people similarly and so
pulling apart I don't think this is a
serious national problem but I think it
is a a negative consequence of having
all this political until I put a public
intellectual
expression on the airwaves Yoopers you
once compared in your own life the
difference between having a social
occasion and a party and talking to
people friends and all versus watching
television and I'm gonna say I was
surprised to learn that do you think you
can learn more from television and you
can from getting around a bunch of
people at a dinner party why because
because you socialize with the people
with whom you're comfortable and you're
comfortable with the people who agree
with you and so it's a kind of echo
chamber effect with to actually a
difference being the intellection
between the television and magazines
magazines tend to be ideologically
monolithic they're liberal and they're
conservative magazines usually the
person who reads the liberal magazine
doesn't read the conservative and vice
versa
television the talk shows make some
effort at balance to having opposed view
so if you watch television you can
actually might actually see a debate and
you might and your views might be
changed you're not going to have that
with a dinner party in that regard
there's a footnote on page 182 that I
wanted you to explain it's footnote 28
and you say I omit the Atlantic Monthly
as it seems to me to have remarkably for
a public intellectual venue no political
leaning how did you get to that point I
tried to look at a number of recent
issues of a number of magazines and the
recent issues of the Atlantic Monthly
that I read didn't seem to me to have a
particular political character they were
all over the place what's your favorite
magazine oh I wouldn't I wouldn't
I I wouldn't make that I wouldn't make
that choice on the ones I read regularly
would be The Times Literary Supplement
New York Review of Books New Republic do
read The Atlantic Monthly I'm actually
I'm writing a I've started writing a
bi-monthly column for The Atlantic
Monthly that has not that that footnote
has nothing to do with that that was
written long before I ever ever had any
dealings with you like monthly what else
do I play who owns the Atlantic Monthly
now who owns it hmm I have no idea so
and Michael Kelly's the editor Michael
Kelly Michael Kelly I might was Michael
Kelly ask me write this column and I
knew not kind I have never met him but I
knew him because he had been the editor
of the New Republic and I thought he had
done an excellent job and I understood
that he had been fired because his
column was too critical of gore so I was
but I had nothing to get forward against
gore but I enjoy his column was very
amusing and so I've always had a high
opinion of him but I think you point out
that Marty parrot zones or did on the
new Republican Wright who was a friend a
teacher of outrage at Harvard yes we the
the what got you the most publicity in
this book or what got you publicity in
this book was this whole chart that you
or this list tell us about the list yeah
I mean I'm embarrassed by the attentions
gotten because maybe this shows my I'm
just out of touch with the real world
but I want to do some statistical work
on public intellectuals because that
hasn't been done before and I was
interested in things like you know what
are the characteristics of successful
public intellectuals terms of age
ethnicity field they've come from
whether they're dead or alive where
they're foreigner
Eric and so how do you how do you study
that and what I what I try to do is to
for what I did was compiled a list
necessarily incomplete and and kind of
catches catch-can of public
intellectuals and I got up to over 500
at that point I thought well this is
this is not either a random or a
complete in either a random sample nor a
complete universe of public
intellectuals so I should make some cut
and what I did was simply did do a have
a computer count made of these five
hundred odd public intellectuals and
compute who well basically who got the
most mentions in the media who received
the most scholarly citations so I've got
the list here the most mentions in the
media starts with Henry Kissinger number
two would be Daniel Patrick Moynihan
George will Larry Summers Bill Bennett
Robert rice Sidney Blumenthal the Sidney
Blumenthal was interesting to me because
from 1995 tonight to 2000 those five
years that you judged all this he was
most of that time in the White House
where he never said anything ya know one
of the prizes when you're trying to do
statistical reasons there's a there's a
trade-off between sort of objectivity
and nuance or precision I mean the
computer that counts people is
completely you know on uncritical that
counts references to people it doesn't
know whether it's whether the reference
is to the person's public intellectual
work or to something else on the other
hand if the if the if the scholar starts
throwing people out of his list saying
well there's not really what he's being
cited for then you have kind of the
accusation that you've cooked your data
so the problem with Sidney Blumenthal is
that undoubtedly most of the references
to him are not to his public
intellectual role but to his role in the
Lewinsky business
and similarly with Henry Kissinger some
of the references to Kissinger are to
his service as Secretary of State rather
than to his public intellectual work
these are both I think serious public
intellectuals Kissinger with his
academic background and his long list of
books and yeah me you know when you see
Kissinger on television discussing and
current problem invariably he will bring
into the problem the historical and you
know philosophical perspective that
marks him as a real intellectual and
Sidney Blumenthal his actual role in the
White House was supposed to be as a kind
of bridge between Blair and Clinton to
try to forge you know a concept of the
Third Way which would be as now trying
to somehow split the difference between
liberals and conservatives that was and
you know public intellectuals in
government that's it that's an old story
you know Seneca was to Nero basically
what Galston and Blumenthal were to
Clinton that is they're the
intellectuals who have the the ear of
the man in power but as you say and as I
acknowledge much of the publicity
Blumenthal received in recent years was
completely unrelated distant work
there's two other things that you seem
to have found and explained them and I'm
not sure I even understand this table is
public intellectual summary statistics
and it appears that for the size of the
population the blacks the percentage
here is 4.8%
whatever that means and then in right
versus left leaning left lending is 66%
right lending is 25% and then Jews and
non-jews that 43 percent of whatever you
found are Jewish which means that
there's very little thought being
pronounced by blacks and an overwhelming
amount on a percentage basis pronounced
by Jews explain that yes and this what
is this poll I mean this this chart so
that I don't know what I did what one of
the reasons I used
drew a sample of 100 for my larger
sample was that with 100 numbers and
percentages are the same right to have
55 black people that's 5% in the larger
I also report however statistics and a
larger sample that's where you get the
4.8% so what this means is that public
intellectuals are not representative of
the population ethnically and this is
not surprising because public
intellectuals tend to be highly educated
people and we know that Jews have been
very much drawn to education and they're
very prominent in universities in the
media and so on and blacks had lagged in
the intellectual profession so that's
not a surprising statistic I think a
more interesting statistic is the other
you mentioned about and I think this is
pretty solid that about two-thirds of
the public intellectuals are on the left
and about a third a little less on the
right I think that's what on the right
that what one sense is terms of the
magazine and newspaper breakdown and the
very and it's an interesting course
disparity between discrepancy between
public intellectual ideology and the
national ideology nationally you know
split quite down the middle but public
intellectual has a love left tilt you
know as the median doing our public
intellectuals are today asked to be
public intellectuals somebody have to
say I'm going to be one rather than a
private intellectual I think so no one
is for no one is forced to are some
people courted avidly some people are
courted there is I mean these magazines
the newspapers and the television radio
shows they have they have a tremendous
demand for commentary and they're
reflecting the demand of people know
newspapers and
oh I think all of the media have become
less focused on just reporting the facts
and more on commentary and
interpretation I think maybe as the
world becomes more complicated people
want interpretation so this is enormous
market out there and so many people
become public intellectuals were
approached by the media rather than
making it their career choice but when
they're approached they find it
attractive and they're off and running
you also have a list of where people
come from who write and talk and the big
areas are specialists in literature and
in history and in philosophy this all
may make sense and the other categories
one of the largest on the list is
journalism and I think the
single-largest is law we better are we
served better by having a lot of our
public intellectuals come from the law
area I don't think that now that that
may reflect my own my own bias or my my
own knowledge that is there's no place
you can go for a list of public
intellectuals you have to make it up
yourself and I think given my background
I would tend to have I would tend to you
know have more lawyers in the in the
list by the other hand you know
obviously people like Alan Dershowitz or
major public intellectuals from the law
side I think what it reflects not that
lawyers have any kind of monopoly of
wisdom adding that but there are so many
legal controversies United States law is
so pervasive and so many political and
economic controversies become recast as
legal that I think it's just inevitable
there'd be a a big market for lawyer
commentary right before this book you
you did two books that were fairly
public one of them was on the
impeachment Bill Clinton and the other
one was on the 2000 election what was
your premise or your findings on the
impeachment in the picking of the
impeachment book
it's hard to it's hard to reduce it to a
single finding I was more interested in
trying to present what I hope would be a
balanced analysis of a legally and
politically very complex question which
I thought had been ill served by the
media and by the public intellectuals as
one of the subordinate themes was and my
conclusion was that there was very
little doubt that President Clinton had
committed serious offenses of a sort
that could have gotten him prosecuted
but on the other hand I didn't think it
was really possible to make a judgment
on impeach ability because there just
are not sufficient guideposts in the
Constitution or in political theory so I
actually thought it I mean I thought I
thought his I thought his misconduct was
serious and I thought it probably was a
good idea that it got a very public
airing but I don't think it would have
been good for the Senate to convict him
and remove him from office I so I was I
was pretty content with with with the
result he had some strong feelings in
the middle of that at least in your book
about public intellectuals academics in
particular signing ads yes the problem
is that if something really new hits
whether it's a presidential impeachment
have only had one before
although Nixon was almost in peace but
you know the Pietschmann is a very rare
a very rare event so it was a big
surprise and then with the election
deadlock you know we have actually had a
election deadlock in the past but it was
in 1876 so that's very new and then the
terror is in the Afghanistan business
that's right now when something very new
comes up the journalists are at a loss
and they cast a
for experts who can fill what becomes an
enormous public demand for informed
commentary problem is they're often very
few experts there are a lot of glib
people who opposes experts and have
credentials and so on
but the result is you get really bad
public intellectual commentary and I
thought in the impeachment case was
really very bad and it's not just very
bad in terms of uninformed but you
mentioned the full-page ads there there
are some genres or formats of public
intellectual activity which are worse
than the op-ed piece or the television
news appearance and that is signing
signing a full-page ad because the
people who sign it are often people who
they may be in the same field as the
person who wrote the ad but they don't
know anything about it so when 400
historians sign a public advertisement
in a full-page advertisement or petition
which says there's no historical basis
for considering President Clinton's
conduct and peaceable well probably 398
of them don't know anything about the
history of impeachment you know history
is a very specialized field being a
historian doesn't mean actually no
history may mean you know the history of
you know Prussia in the 18th century but
you may not know anything about
impeachment so this stuff is kind of
bunk really that was another example was
I think something like twenty five Nobel
scientists signed a petition to
President Clinton saying that a defense
against missile attacks would was
technically infeasible now most of these
people were chemists biologists they
know nothing more about the feasibility
of an anti-missile defense than a lawyer
does and even the physicists who sign it
you know that the issue with an
anti-missile defense basically as I
understand it is ability to discriminate
between actual warheads on an incoming
missile and decoys that's a very
technical esoteric branch of physics
most people physicists are not confident
about that so so this is the worst kind
of kind of you know herd behavior of
intellectuals signing up with their
friends on positions they don't know
anything about your second book that I
mentioned was about the election right
what was your time very similar because
election law is extremely esoteric and
even election technology the punch cards
and and Chad build-up and all that stuff
that's very esoteric so immediately this
and this is something that boils up this
was even faster unfolding than the
impeachment within day you know November
7 the election November 8th by within to
earth within within 48 hours
there was a full-page ad in The New York
Times urging that the election be rerun
in Palm Beach County because of the
butterfly ballot mean crazy stuff you
can't just rerun and the life's probably
unconstitutional infeasible I have to
print up new ballots it's just
ridiculous so this boiled up so quickly
that and there were so few people
knowledgeable about not just election
law but about how the Constitution and
federal law resolved presidential
election deadlock that the public
intellectual commentary was singularly
uninformed so in the end though how did
you come down to the Supreme Court do
the right thing I think what the Supreme
Court did was defensible I think you can
call it right over all and it defensible
but that they handled it very poorly
terms of the grounds they adopted the
things they their their rhetoric they
really shot themselves in the foot I
know I I don't wish to be critical
though because I don't think I would
have done a better I think the problem
was for the court is for the public
intellectuals they were confronted with
something very new very unexpected and
they had very little time to deal with
it so
if you have months to think about things
you know you can you can think about how
it should be done but if you have to
react immediately glare courts aren't
really equipped or I mean they do often
you have to make a tentative ruling
quickly but courts generally not
oriented toward very rapid reactions to
unfolding events it's a more of a
leisured reflective activity that they
try to engage in so they were caught
very much by surprise I think and as
we're the lower fat lower courts
involved like the Florida Supreme Court
so I don't think they should be
criticized it's just you know if
something new hits people they're
usually gonna make a botch of it that's
just this are those are our limitations
let me ask you about that your
relationship with the Supreme Court one
you work for William Brennan as the
curtain for how long the year standard
and since you've been on the Peale's
court they've seen many stories where
you were at some point or another
considered to go on the Supreme Court
well they were yeah newspaper articles
that sort to get any closer than that no
I no one no one in authority ever
approached me and asked me if I was
interested or said I was under
consideration so as far as I know is
just kind of rumor but you have to write
opinions all the time to get bumped to
the Supreme Court and they make a
decision up there on whether they think
you were right yes I've said I wouldn't
say all the time because the the you
know the Supreme Court it's like it's
made of like the brontosaurus you know
brontosaurus had little tiny head not a
huge body so the Supreme Court is the
nine peeve it's kind of frozen this tiny
head and the body consisting of all the
decisions that are appealable the
Supreme Court keeps swelling so the
Supreme Court takes to decide about I
think it's only taking about 80 cases a
year but the federal courts of appeals I
think are grinding out about 10,000
decisions a year
and the state Supreme Court's at least
as many so actually to have one of your
decisions reviewed by the Supreme Court
look like being struck by lightning
every once in a while it happens but
I've written almost a 2,000 opinions and
I doubt that more than 10 or 12 have
actually let going to the Supreme Court
the reason I bring it up is that wonder
if you did you ever worry that
criticizing the Supreme Court in the
book would ever hurt you in the future
when they're looking at one of your
decisions no no I don't think their
petty in that in that way and for one
thing even if I well no I don't think
they're I don't think there patty I
think they understand that you can't be
a Supreme Court justice and escape
professional criticism that that's just
comes with a with a with a job but but
in addition to that even if particular
justice is harbored particularly
animosity to lower court judges the
stakes in their decisions are too great
for them to allow that to influence
their their a work and and my dealings
with I know I don't know all of this
between quite resume I know most of them
and they're they're very gracious in
their dealings with the other judges and
no I I don't let me go back to your last
list because you've observed education
all your life and it looked at the
difference between the blacks and their
position as public intellectuals and the
Jews and you go to the Jewish people
have a real interest in education how do
you flip this thing over in the future
howdy is it possible to change and to
get people who have not been interested
in education interested and it how would
you go about it
well it's very difficult because you
know cultural cultural traits are often
more difficult to change than biological
traits you're gonna have you can have
plastic surgery or something and but you
but when you have a deep-rooted and for
example so with the Jews going back to
you know biblical times there has always
been this a tremendous significance
attached to the written word to the to
the Bible and then to its elaboration
and the Talmud and it's just and partly
because of discrimination against Jews
they just were channeled into but
whatever it is there is this heavy
emphasis in Jewish culture on education
and intellectual activity and on the
other hand and a number of black
professionals have made this point
people like Orlando Patterson for
example there's an anti-intellectual a
streak a strong anti intellectual streak
in the black culture in the United
States where kids are ridiculed you know
by other kids for any interest in
education it's considered you know
whitey stuff and so so and there are
people like Patterson you know who
recognize this is a problem and I want
to change it how that how one does that
I don't I don't that's not my area where
what was your own personal atmosphere
when you were growing up or did you were
you born New York City yeah and that
where were you educated in New York well
private schools
Walden Columbia grammar ethical culture
then my family moved to Scarsdale when I
was nine then I went to public schools
public school and what were your parents
there oh they were my father was a
lawyer and a business
man my mother taught English in New York
public high schools and they were no
actually they were quite left-wing and
Jewish people and they had gone to
public college in New York they were
immigrants but they came over his
children so they were fully assimilated
from my father was born in Romania and
my mother in Austria was there a
difference in if you're from Austria
from Romania and the family was there
did it matter where they were from yes
because because German including
Austrian Jews looked down on Eastern
European Jews so my mother although they
both grew up in great poverty in the
Lower East Side
my mother's family looked down on my
father's family partly because of this
difference in the country of origin
partly because only we're both very poor
families my mother's family was a little
more a little better off so we do you
remember the first time that you or you
remember the atmosphere and what you
started to want to learn oh yes yes well
it was particularly yes my mother my
mother started reading I well she
started reading Shakespeare to me when I
was an infant and the Odyssey I know she
I remember the copy of the Odyssey we
had in which she had to remove the
picture of this Cyclops because it
frightened me so that I must have been
three in fact I remember being taken to
the Laurence Olivier Henry the fifth
when I and that was that was that that
movie was issued in 1942 when I was
three so there was a lot of this kind of
I wouldn't call it forest feeding but
they were my mother's certainly made a
big effort to
introduced me to culture from the
earliest possible age well in the
atmosphere in our how home was very much
that again you have very different
emphasis didn't care about my doing
sports or anything like that they wanted
me to you know read and get good grades
I wanted me to have a social life and be
a normal kid but the the focus was on
you know being a good student being
academically successful going to the
best possible college having some kind
of having a career that would have
professional dignity not not just the
money money grubbing in your book you
say that Shakespeare and Henry James and
TS Eliot and Charles Dickens were
anti-semitic true
yes although when you put it that boldly
it makes it sound like a criticism which
was not my intention it's just it's it's
just the well the reason I bring up the
culture it's just the color but also I
you do want to make a distinction
between I mean before you know nineteen
fifty or so casual anti-semitism or
negative remarks about Jews were just
part of of Western culture and and they
were pervasive and they didn't reflect I
think any particular hostility it was
just the way people talk there have
always been a serious anti-semites that
is people you know people have Jews on
the brain and in the in the cultural
tradition someone like Ezra Pound would
be an example it was a real
preoccupation for him he's a serious
anti-semite but someone like Eliot er
Shakespeare Dickens or James well you'll
just notice anti-semitic passages in
their works I don't consider that to be
serious I don't remember the context
which I have mentioned that well you say
though that most public intellectuals
are that they're not when they talk
about the present they're not very happy
what about the future and what about
your look into the future are you
positive negative and after you see the
decline of public intellectuals where're
we going with all of us I don't know
what the future holds I the the I think
the the most powerful indictment that
can be made against public intellectuals
is precisely their efforts to predict
the future
that's what we you see the most absurd
mistakes so I want to I don't want to
fall into that swamp by making
predictions in fact I think there is
such enormous complexity in the modern
world that it's really impossible to
make responsible predictions I don't see
any reason to be pessimistic but on the
other hand
there's such pervasive unserved we're
continuously being surprised and that
means that we really don't have a very
good sense of what the future always
harvard bad press published this book do
they and publish all your books no most
of them some have been published by
academic other academic presses and some
and text I have a couple of textbooks
that have been published by but it look
like some puppies intellectuals well how
many would they print the first run on
this I don't I I don't know I I think
probably 10,000 would be the upper limit
of a her first write butchers are not
big sellers what's your bestseller
well I have a textbook called economic
analysis of law which has been in print
since 1973 and but in successive
editions not exactly it's not really the
same book but it I think over you know
period almost 30 years sold a lot of
books in terms of one I think the I
think my my book on Clinton's
impeachment sold I think more than
25,000 copies in hardback nice and
paperback this is very far from
bestseller done our guest has been a
judge at the US Court of Appeals in
Chicago Seventh Circuit his book is
public intellectuals a study of decline
Richard Posner thank you very much for
joining us thank you my pleasure